Although they’re often electric,
on-screen kisses aren’t always
planned. From the tender to the funny to the
deeply controversial, here are a few on-screen
kisses that were never supposed to happen.
One of Lost in Translation’s most iconic scenes
revolves around the tender moment shared at the
end of the movie between Scarlett Johansson’s
Charlotte and Bill Murray’s character Bob. During
filming, Murray famously whispered something in
Johansson's ear that neither actor has revealed.
The ensuing kiss wasn’t planned, either.
*Bob kisses Charlotte*
When asked about the scene, director
Sofia Coppola told The Daily Beast,
"I remember sometimes [Murray]
would spring things on [Johansson],
and it was fun to get her reaction."
During Stranger Things 2’s season finale,
Lucas and newcomer Max share a kiss at their
school’s winter dance. In an episode of the
aftershow series Beyond Stranger Things, Sadie
Sink — who played Max — explained that the kiss
was a surprise and that showrunners Matt and
Ross Duffer sprang it on her the day of filming.
"Oh, Sadie, you ready for the kiss?"
"I’m like, what? No! No, that’s not
in the script. You can’t, that’s not happening."
Ross Duffer had previously joked with Sink
about her kissing her co-star Caleb McLaughlin,
and the idea had stressed her out so much
that he decided to have it happen for real.
It was a decision which sparked outrage
online. In the wake of the controversy,
Sink told TheWrap that she had “always
felt comfortable” on set, saying
“[The Duffer Brothers] always create a comfortable
space. And if I felt uncomfortable with
anything, I wouldn’t have done it.”
"Anyways, it's great. I can’t
imagine it without it. Thank you."
"Yeah. You're welcome."
Luke and Leia’s scene towards
the end of The Last Jedi is arguably
one of the movie’s finest moments.
It’s an exchange which carries
extra weight considering Carrie
Fisher’s tragic passing only months after
filming ended. The scene is punctuated by
a forehead kiss from Luke to Leia which
was improvised on Mark Hamill’s part.
"It was just spontaneous, and really momentous
for me because Luke was saying
goodbye to his sister forever."
Hamill has been unable to watch the scene since.
“She’ll be forever missed,
and she’s irreplaceable.”
After the home release of The Hunger Games:
Mockingjay – Part 2, Woody Harrelson told
Entertainment Tonight that his on-screen kiss with
Elizabeth Banks had nothing to do with the script.
"She didn't know I was even gonna
do it, and I just kissed her."
Harrelson later told the Associated Press,
“I, personally, always wanted to kiss her. I
don't know if it was the right thing to do."]
Although Harrelson denied knowing it, the
AP’s reporter claimed she'd heard that Banks
intentionally flubbed takes during the scene
so she could keep locking lips with Harrelson.
Thanks to the logistical realities
of filming a television show,
an unplanned kiss between two actors can
often involve more people than initially
intended. That’s what happened after Game
of Thrones actors Gemma Whelan and Indira
Varma improvised a kiss between their
characters Yara Greyjoy and Ellaria Sand.
“Leave him be. Seems like
you don’t need a protector.”
This moment takes place on a ship just prior to
an attack by antagonist Euron Greyjoy. Whelan's
back was injured at the time, however, and
since she couldn't perform all of her stunts,
her double was brought in to replace
her — and also had to kiss Varma.
Varma told Entertainment Weekly that
“I had to start kissing this poor stunt
double and she was so terrified. I don't
think she'd ever been put in that situation
before. She's used to falling over and
being attacked and all the stunts, but to be
kissed by an actress was a bit beyond her."
According to Bryce Dallas Howard, the
kiss between her character Claire and
Chris Pratt’s Owen was never in the script
for Jurassic World. She told Out Magazine,
"We had shot the scene in the way
that it was written — there was no
kiss. And then on the last day, that
happened — what you see in the movie."
The movie’s director, Colin Trevorrow,
however, has since revealed that it wasn’t
entirely spontaneous. He took Pratt
aside and suggested he kiss Howard,
but never told her. On Jurassic
World’s commentary, he explained:
"The idea was we're just going to have Chris
Pratt surprise [Howard] in front of 200 people,
and that's the take that's in the movie."
During the season 3 premiere of The Office,
Steve Carell’s character Michael learns
that his employee Oscar — played by Oscar
Nuñez — is gay. In a misguided attempt to
prove how tolerant he is… this happens.
*Michael kisses Oscar*
According to Nuñez, however, the script only
called for Carell to hug him. He told the AV Club,
"We were just supposed to hug, and he
kept hugging me. And that particular
take he came in really close, and I'm
like, 'Where is he going with this?'"
”Thank you.”
”See?”
David O. Russell didn't cast Jennifer Lawrence in
his 2013 black comedy American Hustle until very
late into the casting process. The director told
Vanity Fair that even though she was young for
the role, Lawrence had a, quote, "timeless
quality," and that "she took to the part,
chemically." Since we’re talking about
an improvised kiss scene between Lawrence
and Amy Adams, it would be interesting to learn
exactly which chemicals Russell was talking about.
Lawrence played Rosalyn Rosenfeld,
wife to conman Irving Rosenfeld,
played by Christian Bale. At
a pivotal moment in the film,
Rosalyn argues with Irving's mistress Sydney,
played by Amy Adams, in a bathroom, and in the
middle of the confrontation Rosalyn aggressively
kisses Sydney and then bursts into cruel laughter.
Russell said the kiss was improvised, recalling
that the idea was pitched to him, but that it
didn’t exactly fit his vision. In a 2013 press
conference about the movie, Adams said even though
the kiss was her idea, the credit for the moment
goes to Lawrence. Adams went on to say the kiss:
"[...] didn't just feel like
a moment where two girls are
going to kiss onscreen it felt emotional,"
and called Lawrence's laugh
that followed the kiss "genius."
*laughter*
In 2014's Edge of Tomorrow, United
Defense Force Major William Cage,
played by Tom Cruise, is arrested by a superior
officer for insubordination during an alien
invasion. After his records are deliberately
altered to make it look like he's a private,
Cage is forced into action, where he quickly
dies in battle only to discover he's trapped
in a time loop where he relives the same
day leading up to his death over and over.
His only ally is Rita Vrataski, played by
Emily Blunt, a highly regarded sergeant
who's also the only person who accepts
that his time-looping dilemma is real.
“Find me when you wake up.”
Speaking to Film School Rejects, screenwriter
Christopher McQuarrie said the filmmakers
struggled to find a place in the
film for Cage and Rita to kiss,
but nothing they tried seemed genuine. He said:
"[I]t always felt false. It always felt like they
weren't focused on what was really important."
McQuarrie and his colleagues gave up on
the kiss completely, but apparently Blunt
hadn't. McQuarrie said that as they shot a
scene in which Rita says goodbye to Cage:
"[Blunt] just kissed him goodbye in the moment.
And it was not in the script.
It was not even discussed."
According to McQuarrie after the
scene was filmed, Blunt said:
"It just felt right. It felt right and I did it."
In season 4 of Riverdale, CW's teen drama
paid tribute to Hedwig and the Angry Inch,
a stage musical later adapted to film about an
East German trans rock singer in the '80s. In
the episode "Chapter Seventy-Four: Wicked Little
Town," Casey Cott’s Kevin Keller decides it's time
for Riverdale High to host variety shows again.
When Principal Honey warns Kevin not to perform
any numbers from Hedwig, Kevin and his friends
fight back by performing multiple numbers from
the musical. During the Hedwig original "Tear
Me Down" Kevin and K.J. Apa’s Archie lock lips,
and according to Cott even though the kiss was
never planned, it absolutely had to happen.
Cott explained to TV Insider that there's
a part of the Hedwig stage musical when
the titular hero goes into the audience and
kisses an audience member. Inspired by this,
while filming his performance of "Tear Me
Down" with Cott's Kevin Keller playing Hedwig,
Cott kissed Apa on the cheek.
But then, as Cott explained:
"[...] the next take I went in to
do the same thing and [Apa] turned
his face and we just kind of laid a big
one on each other. And then after that,
we were like 'This is exactly what it should
be. This is, like, perfect for this number.'"
Thankfully, everyone agreed,
and the kiss made the final cut.
From the beginning of the sci-fi
crime drama Person of Interest,
fans noticed romantic tension between
Jim Caviezel’s CIA operative, John Reese,
and NYPD Detective Joss Carter, played
by Taraji P. Henson. However, it takes
until the third season for those feelings
to find any kind of physical expression.
In season 3's "The Crossing," Reese and Carter
finally share a kiss while they're hiding from the
bad guys in a morgue; sadly, it's destined to be
their first and last. At the end of the episode,
the corrupt cop Patrick Simmons ambushes them
and shoots them both before running away.
They're both hit, but Carter is mortally
wounded and she dies in Reese's arms.
According to the show's producers, even though
the kiss was a landmark moment for the characters,
it was a decision the actors made
completely on their own. Person
of Interest executive producer Greg
Plageman told The Hollywood Reporter:
"[...] the kiss was not scripted. We never
wrote it in [...] It wasn't in every take;
there were takes where they didn't do
it and there were takes where they did."
Plageman went on to say that when they
looked at the takes without the kiss, it
felt like something was missing and that the kiss
deepened the connection between the characters.
Sometimes, an unplanned kiss in a
TV show or a movie will generate
controversy felt well outside the editing room,
and that's something Tommy Davidson learned
while filming the 1998 romantic comedy Woo.
Jada Pinkett Smith played Davidson's love interest
in the romcom, and in his 2020 memoir Living in
Color: What's Funny About Me, Davidson writes
that neither he nor Smith were satisfied with
the script's ending. He says he pitched the
idea of ending Woo with the couple dancing
in the middle of a city street, and apparently
everyone liked the idea. While dancing with his
co-star in the new scene, Davidson kissed Smith
without warning. Though he said Smith flinched
when he kissed her, at the time he, quote,
"didn't think it was all that big of a deal."
But there was someone who thought it was
a big deal Jada Pinkett Smith's husband,
Will Smith. According to Davidson, after
the scene was shot, Will Smith followed
Davidson into his trailer and things got very
heated between the two. Davidson explained:
"There was a moment there when
we might have come to blows. My
reactive fight-or-flight instinct was
triggered and I could have exploded."
Thankfully, Jada stepped in and
helped to calm things down, and
Davidson and Will remained good friends afterward.
“I was just about to retaliate!”
Between the '60s and '80s, Valerie Leon made
a name for herself playing young beauties,
particularly in James Bond flicks she appeared
in both 1977's The Spy Who Loved Me and 1983's
Never Say Never Again. In a 2017 interview with
WestEndExtra, Leon named one of the Bond actors
Roger Moore as one of her favorite actors to
work with. Along with The Spy Who Loved Me,
she worked with Moore in the TV series The
Saint and the 1978 war film The Wild Geese.
But Leon said that one of her favorite
collaborations with Moore was on the early
'70s action comedy TV series The Persuaders! She
appears as Space Queen in "The Long Goodbye,"
as one of a number of women claiming to be
heiress to a dead scientist. She recalled:
"Roger gave me an unscripted kiss. I just
closed my eyes and enjoyed it. They kept it in."
There have been plenty of steamy moments
on the medical drama Grey's Anatomy,
but in the show's season 14 finale,
there was one that was less steamy but plenty
surprising for almost everyone involved.
Early in the episode "All of Me" even though she's
about to get married to Justin Chambers’ Alex,
and everyone insists they can't see one another
before the wedding Camilla Luddington’s Jo rushes
to see Alex and her other friends, because
she has news she can't keep to herself.
She's just learned she's been tapped for
a highly sought-after surgery fellowship
at Massachusetts General Hospital. Ignoring
all the protests about not seeing her fiancé,
Jo announces it to her fiends, predictably
kisses Alex, and then much less predictably
kisses Jessica Capshaw’s Arizona,
before giving her fiancé a second kiss.
It's just a quick kiss but Capshaw is
visibly surprised, and the moment didn't
go unnoticed by the audience. Asked about
the kiss on Twitter, Luddington responded:
"Ha!!! It was unscripted but I thought hello?!!!
Who wouldn't want to also smooch Arizona Robbins."
Fittingly, you could interpret
it as a kiss goodbye, as "All of
Me" was Capshaw's final appearance on the series.
The Model Elle Macpherson hasn't done a lot of
acting work, and when she starred in 1997's The
Edge, she'd done even less. Macpherson plays
Mickey, wife of billionaire Charles Morse,
played by Anthony Hopkins. Hopkins and co-star
Alec Baldwin who plays photographer Bob Green
have the lion's share of screen time. Early
in the film Morse suspects Bob is having an
affair with Mickey, and this is confirmed at a
particularly inconvenient time when Morse and
Green are trapped in the wilderness and fighting
for their lives against a massive Kodiak bear.
In a 2011 episode of The Graham Norton Show,
Macpherson said her unexpected kiss with Hopkins
took place during the auditioning process for
The Edge rather than during the filming; and it
wasn't so much that the kiss was unexpected,
but the type of kiss was a shock. She said,
during the audition, the casting directors
emphasized that in spite of the 27-year
age difference between her and Hopkins it was
important that they feel, quote, "connected" and
"intimate with each other," so it was suggested
they kiss. Macpherson explained to Norton that,
having not done much acting work, she wasn't
sure if she should, quote, "kiss with the tongue,
without the tongue," and she erred on
the side of, well... the side of tongue.
"He went so red. He was
flustered I got the job, though."